we begin with what was supposed to be a
fun night for glorilla fans in New York
to quickly turned tragic here are the
latest details
this is a tragedy of Epic Proportions I
just was trying to get out of there the
crowd began to Surge and Rush toward the
exit I am devastated and heartbroken
that from 23 year old rapper glorilla
who spoke out after the Stampede at her
Rochester concert left two women dead
today we're learning more about what
caused The Surge I hope that nobody is
still shaken up like I am we spoke to
sinquest Anderson who shot this phone
video just five minutes before the chaos
everyone is headed towards the door and
unknown commotion caused people to just
surge to the front of the building and
it just was out of control from there we
were hearing many reports of potential
causes including possibly crowd size
shots fired pepper spray and other
contributing factors
glorilla a rising star in the world of
rap performed with cardi B at the amas
last year that girl really has your back
what's it like to have cardi B support
it's a thing that's my Disney I love her
you know and just last month she was
part of the Grammy's 50th celebration of
hip-hop
this time I always wanted to do and I
didn't know it was gonna come
back while the investigation continues
Beyonce Taylor and Madonna prepare for
their tours the question is how do you
survive a crowd Crush crowd safety
expert Paul wertheimer with three tips
number one you want to stay standy you
want to help others around you stay
standy number two create space keep your
arms in front of you that creates a
pocket of space between you and the
person in front of you and number three
don't yell or scream that uses up vital
oxygen you need to survive
[Music]